[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Yeniden başla
Ümitli aşkla
rüzgarlarla seviş mutlu Özgür
Yeniden Başla
ümitle aşkla
rüzgarlarla seviş mutlu Özgür Her sabah
hayatımıza yeniden başlıyoruz bugün
bundan sonraki hayatımızın ilk günü
Peki hayatınızda kim yön veriyor
hayatınıza ne yön veriyor anneniz
Babanız eşiniz çocuklarınız duygularınız
hayatınıza ne yön veriyor hiç düşündünüz
mü
benim hayatıma Hayallerim yön verdi
kendimi bildiğim anda beri Öğretmen
olmak istedim ilkokulda öyle Ortaokulda
öyle ne zaman ne olacaksın diye sorsalar
hep Öğretmen olmak istediğini söyledi
Sonra bir gün sanıyorum ortaokul son
sınıftayız ailecek bir tiyatro oyunu
izlemeye gittik şehir tiyatrolarında
Katerina
oyundan çıktık Haşim işten geçidinden
Otobüs duraklarına doğru yürüyoruz
ailemle benim Gözyaşlarım rüzgara
karışmaya başladı hüngür hüngür
ağlıyorum kendimi tutamıyorum çünkü o
akşam bir karar verdim tiyatro sanatçısı
olacağım Hani öğretmen olacaktım olamaz
mı ikisini birden yapabilirim hem
Öğretmen olmak istiyorum Hem tiyatro
sanatçısı olmak istiyorum Çok iddialıyım
bu konuda
liseye gitmeye başladığım sırada
üniversite sınavları heyecanı
Paramız yoktu Ailem beni dershaneye
gönderemedi ben kendi başıma
üniversiteye hazırlanıyorum İstanbul
Üniversitesi Edebiyat Fakültesi en büyük
hayalim ve Mimar Sinan Üniversitesi
Devlet konservatuvarda ikinci büyük
hayali sınavlara Hazırlandım Hazırlandım
Hazırlandım kendimce girdim sonuçlara
açıklandı İstanbul Üniversitesi Edebiyat
fakültesini kazanamamıştım Mimar Sinan
Üniversitesi Devlet konservatuarı'nda
kazanamadım ne kazandım dersiniz
Eskişehir Anadolu Üniversitesi
Açıköğretim Fakültesi İktisat
Yapacak bir şey yok İktisat okumaya
başladım bir yandan çalışıyorum
tekrar denemeye karar verdim Hani
Yeniden Başla şarkısını seviyorum ya
orada da bu şarkıyı söylüyorum Yeniden
Başla yeniden çalış Konservatuarı ikinci
senede girdim yine kazanamadım
3 sene kazandım Nihayet hayallerimden
birine ulaşmıştım bu birinci Hayal cepte
ikinci Hayal Öğretmen olmak isteği
konservatuarın ilk yıllarından itibaren
bütün öğretmenlerimi asiste ettim şimdi
Rahmetli olan Haluk kurdu oğlunu zekaya
müftüoğlu'nu
onlar rahmetli diye saygıyla anıyorum
Cihan Ünal'ı Zeliha Berk soyu asiste
ettim nasıl yapıyorlar hepsini öğrenmek
istedim İyi bir öğretmen olmak
istiyordum bu çabalarıma da değdi Zeliha
Hoca Bakırköy Belediye tiyatrolarının
çocuk eğitim kulübüne beni çağırdı Orada
çocuklar eğitmeye başladım bugün
içlerinde çok ünlü olan mini mini
çocuklar hepsi o dönemden tanıdıklarım
öğrencilerim oldular sonra Şehit
tiyatroların çocuk eğitim birimine de
gittim orada da uzun yıllar çalıştım bir
sürü kurumda kuruluşta yaratıcı drama
eğitmenliği oyunculuk koçluğu Yaptım
bundan 10-12 yıl önce de dedim ki artık
kendi süsü nasıl yapıldığını biliyorum
Yeniden Başla şarkısını da seviyorum ve
Hadi dedim kolları sıvayalım başlayalım
küçük böyle Kömürlük benzeri bir yer
tuttum gayrettepe'de içini boyadım iki
tane arkadaşımı çağırdım Onlar da bana
ortak olmak istediler hep birlikte
boyalar badanalar alışverişler Şahane
sıra geldi müşteri bulmaya iş dünyasına
iletişim eğitimi vereceğiz ve çocuklara
drama eğitimi vereceğiz ve büyüklere de
deli gibi yazışıyoruz mailler atıyoruz
sağa sola derken bir tanesi geri döndüm
müşterilerinizden Evet Sizinle çalışmak
istiyoruz dedi
heyecanlıyız Bir sabah bir telefon çaldı
işi bize verecek beyefendi Süheda Hanım
dedi Kusura bakmayın biz bu işi kurumsal
yapmamaya karar verdik bireysel olarak
çalışacağız hiçbir şey anlamadım Ne
demek bu ha sonra iş anlaşıldı ki
ortaklarımdan güzel gözlü olan
hanımefendi ile birlikte çalışmaya karar
vermişler
çalıştılar da o işi yaptı o güzel gözlü
ortam Tabii benimle ortaklığını ayırdı
Ben de artık onlarla çalışmak istemezdim
böyle bu mesele devam etti çok kırıldım
çok üzüldüm iki ortaktan da ayrılmıştım
tek başımayım Yeniden Başla tekrar çalış
çabala çalış çabala şehir dışında
eğitimlere gidiyorum İstanbul'da
eğitimler yapıyorum bir asistan'a
ihtiyacım oldu
asistan'ı da buldum Kıza dedim ki bu da
evimin anahtarı Çünkü stüdyo ile ev çok
yakın
yani başın ağrır ağrı kesici alırsın
gidersin gelirsin
hanımefendi ağrı kesici dışında her
şeyimi aldı beni periyodik olarak soydu
böyle bir gün bir küpemi bulamıyorum bir
gün bir zincirimi bulamıyorum bir gün
şehir dışından eğitimden geldim
stüdyodaki diğer malzemeleri de
bulamadım her şeyimi çalmıştı Evet o bir
yıl hapis yattı ama benim iş
dünyasındaki İkinci büyük yenilgimdi
küstüm kapattım evime çekildim
yapmayacağım bu işi dedim
çeşitli eğitimler almaya devam ediyorum
Bir sabah bir yazı okudum diyor ki
girişimcilerin yüzde sekseni ilk
denemelerinde başarısız olur ama tekrar
denemeye karar veren %20'nin
%85'i Başarır Peki şimdi Hangi şarkıyı
söylüyoruz Yeniden başla
başladım bu sefer Kömürlük gibi olmayan
bahçe katı bir daire tuttum Çok güzel
gözler olmayan bir de ortak aldım yanıma
o kızla çalışmaya başladık alışverişler
kameralar televizyonlar her şeyimiz
hazır oyuncu koçluğu yapacağız İlk hafta
hırsız girdi
her şeyimiz çalındı ve ortağım kız dedi
ki ben bu masrafları bir kere daha
yapamam ben gidiyorum
Ondan bir süre önce de nişanlanmıştım
işte nişanında bir şeyleri toparlamaya
gayret etti filan O kendi işini yapıyor
ben kendi işimi yapıyorum Çok
çalışıyorum yine gidiyorum geliyorum
işler büyüdü tek odaya yetmez oldum
cadde üzerinde 5 odalı bir yer bulduk bu
sefer unuttum
nişanlımın işleri kötüye gittiği için
döndü bana dedi ki ben senin genel
müdürün olayım şu odayı bana ver Benden
Ne münasebet O senin için bu benim işim
Hayır dedi bu cevabından hiç hoşlanmadı
o kadar hoşlanmadı ki bana da
hoşlanmadığım şeyler yaptı
tüm kitaplarımı yaktı bir sabah elimde
sadece iç çamaşırlarımın olduğu Valizle
evlenince beraber oturacağımızı
düşündüğümüz içindeki çeyizleri kendi
paramla yaptığım evden ayrılmak zorunda
kaldım
şimdiki şarkımız ne Yeniden Başla
yeniden başladı küçük bir daire
kenardaki param sadece daireyi tutmaya
iyi etti içine koyacak eşyam yok
ikinci el eşyaları aldı
50 yaşımda
başkalarının kullandığı çamaşır
makinesinde çamaşır yıkadım
başkalarının yemek yaptığı ocakta yemek
ama hayalim var tutkum var onun peşinden
gidiyorum yine çok çalıştım Her şeyi
toparladım bütün eşyalarımı sıfırlarım
dediğim anda pandemi patladı
öğrenci gelmiyor
kolları tekrar sıvadım aklım başıma
devşirdim ne yaparım ne yaparım okula
taşındım 5 odası var ya Okulun 2 minik
odada 3 yıl Mutfağı olmayan bir evde
yaşadım
Çünkü Bilirim ki Gecenin en karanlık anı
sabaha en yakın olandır Çünkü Bilirim ki
sabahlar sihirlidir
Çünkü çekoara ne demiştir
kaybettiğinde değil
vazgeçtiğimde yenilirsin Ben yenilmeyi
hiç kabul etmedim her seferinde yeniden
başlama gücünü buldum kendimde bunu en
çok Sabahları buldum biliyor musunuz
Sabahları erken kalkarım 6'da lise
yıllarımdan böyle Kimileri gece ders
çalışır Ben sabahları ders çalışayım
Çünkü tanıdığım bütün adamlar bütün
Büyük adamlar sabah erken kalkar
Müşrikler konservatuvarda 7.30'da prova
koyardı hiçbir provaya geç kalmadı
Haldun görmen Yaygara 70 provaları
sırasında anlattı çocukluğundan beri o
kadar erken kalkarmış ki bir sabah 9'a
kadar uyumuş evladım Ailesi Ortalığı
ayağa kaldırmış Haldun öldü herhalde
diye
Apple'ın eski CEO'su Steve Jobs her
sabah 6'da kalkan yeni CEO'su 03.45
Bunlar boşuna değil hiçbir başarı
tesadüf değildir ve sabahlar sihirlidir
sabahlardan enerji Yağar Ben okuldaki
alışkanlığımı televizyon oyunculuğu
yaptım sırada setlere de taşıdım bir gün
çok uzakta bir yerde setimiz gittim o
kadar erken ki kimse yok Arabam bagajına
battaniye aldım sarıldım bekliyorum
uyumuşum zar zar zar telefon çalıyor kız
ya Hocam neredesiniz Sizi bekliyoruz
sizi dedim ki arka Bahçedeyim rahat
olsun Onlar benim bu Adetimi bilmediği
için boşuna telaşlanmışlardı mesela
erken kalkıp zamanı kazanmak Düşünsenize
haftanın her günü bir saat erken
kalksanız Aslında haftayı 8 gün
yaşıyorsunuz Çünkü 7 saat kazanıyorsunuz
mesela erken kalkmanın yanında hayaliniz
için bir şey yapmak herhangi bir şey
okumak yazmak resim çizmek Her Şey
Olabilir Ben bugün stüdyodaki
öğrencilerime bilerek Onların haberi yok
her gün Aşağı yukarı 20 dakika tutacak
ödevler verir ve her hafta
Buluştuğumuzda
haftada kaç gün o 20 dakikayı
kullandığını hemen anlarım
bir sürü dijital içerik üreticisi Hilmi
Öğütçü Bununla ilgili bir yazı yazmıştı
20 dakika kuralı diye 20 dakikada gün
içinde kendinize ayırdığınız 20 dakikada
Neredeyse her sorunuzu halledebilirsiniz
dağınıklıktan şikayetçiyseniz her gün 20
dakika ortalığı topladığınızda böyle bir
şikayetiniz kalmaz artık mesela Canan
Karatay bile diyor ki deli gibi spor
yapmanıza gerek yok günde 20 dakika
yürüyün sağlıklı ve zinde olursunuz
mesele bir şeyler yapmaya üşenmemek
Çünkü bu geçirilen zamanda erken uyanıp
o uğurda bir şeyler yapmanın sonunda çok
güzel bir yere geliyorsunuz Ben Sizin
karşınızda hayallerini gerçekleştirmiş
biriyim bunu erken kalkmaya borçluyum
bunu her gün 20 dakika bu uğurda bir
şeyler yapıyor olmama borçluyum
yolun sonunda ışık var bu ışığa yürümeye
devam edin
Ne demiş şair Yeter ki kararmasın son
demenin altındaki Cevahir teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]